[Music]
jack we're gonna talk about rainbows my
eight-year-old daughter loves rainbows
okay well make sure she listens to this
all right so that's cool yeah so it was
not until isaac newton
my man
that's my boy okay early 1700s he wrote
a book in with 1704 it was just called
optics
one of the rare books that he actually
wrote in english
all his other books were in latin which
was the
the you know he really was a nerd
okay
but in there he figured something out
okay everyone of course had known about
the colors of the rainbow red orange
yellow green blue violet every okay and
people have seen you know chandelier
light will come through the chandelier
and you'd see
rainbow colors come out one side or
another
everybody until newton
presumed that those colors were somehow
getting generated
inside the chandelier glass okay or
inside the raindrop
right there was some property of the
medium itself
nobody was thinking
that pure white light is composed of
those colors
oh if only we could learn that lesson in
our society
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're getting all sociological
so imagine if martin luther king were
more physics fluent that would make a
whole different i have a dream speech
i have a dream
that one day we will recognize
the white black red or brown
we're all white
[Laughter]
people it's okay
it's okay
everybody would have tipped their head
and said what it's what we invited this
man to be with you
i may not get there with you but we'll
all be white one day
okay so here's how he did it okay so he
puts white light through a prism
okay
and out the other side comes the colors
of the rainbow much as what we all
remember from pink floyd's dark side of
the moon album cover one of the best
ever
all right so
he then and this is what makes newton
newton he said let me take another prism
and put it upside down next to it
oh
okay and this will kind of reverse what
had just happened
and when he did that out the second
prism came white light
okay how did i not hear
and all the time we've been working
together this is the first time i've
ever heard this story yes
this is brilliant yes
because in doing so
he proves that it has nothing to do
with the actual medium itself that the
light coming in
was merely separated
and then by coming out and going back
into another medium
it combines it's the light it's just the
light
that's why he is isaac newton and the
rest of us aren't it's that wow
that is brilliant and it's simple and
brilliant yes yeah exactly that's what
makes it extra brilliant is how simple
it is so at that point it's easy to sort
of extrapolate
that a rainbow is just sunlight broken
up into those same colors that the prism
did for you
okay
so now what's going on inside a raindrop
so sunlight enters the raindrop at a
particular angle
all right actually comes in at all
angles but only one of those angles will
internally reflect
off the boundary between the raindrop
and the air
okay this is this is the one of the most
fascinating features of optics
okay so so in other words if i'm
underwater and i let's say i have a
laser so we get a nice sharp point and i
point it upwards not straight up but at
an angle that's a slight angle when that
laser beam exits
into the air
it bends
okay it's bent
it's bent okay okay you can picture this
you can try it yourself if you have a
pocket laser okay so
it's easy then to
expect that a similar thing is happening
between sunlight and rain drops that was
happening between your sunlight and your
prism
so
but the fun part is the sunlight goes
inside the raindrop
and bounces around a couple of times
before it exits again
and by the time it exits
all of those colors have been separated
out from the white light
and thus you have this participatory
rainbow where all of these dots of uh
all these droplets of water participate
in one coherent rainbow
now
the the the angle the light exits
creates a rainbow that you see
okay right okay right you you only see
what enters your eye you can't see what
doesn't enter your eye correct right
that makes sense
by the way that itself was a discovery
from a thousand years ago um uh ibn
al-haytham
was a a muslim
scientist back in the the golden age of
islam he was the first to deduce that
sight
is not you beaming stuff out of your
eyes
it's completely passive
your eyeballs are just sitting there
waiting for light to enter and for your
brain to then make an image this is
profound because before then you had
these legends like like like uh medusa
yeah all right
how does medusa work how does that work
well when you look her in the eyes she
turns you to stone basically
she turns you
right into stone because she's casting
whatever from her eyes
that's correct
you could only think that if you have no
idea how vision works
right right or or if you're creating
x-men but that's it
oh he's got yeah he's got his little
visor thing that can send out the beams
so what that means is
all of the rainbow light
that's coming to you is exiting those
raindrops at the precise angle that
enters your eyeballs
okay
okay
that means
your rainbow
is unique to you
wow
when if i stand to your left or right
above doesn't matter if i stand
somewhere else and we're looking at
quote the same rainbow we tell ourselves
we're not
you know what this fact means
i did not okay
every rainbow you have ever seen has
been exactly face on to you aha
and so i am
every rainbow
actually was made just for me just for
you you have never witnessed a rainbow
at an angle angle
right
so think about that because if your
rainbow was a real thing in the sky
i could
move to another location and look at it
from a different angle right if it was
an actual thing like anything else right
like a mountain a tree or anything like
anything else okay
so
if you wanted to go to the base of the
rainbow
you can't
ah
because that would be taking a different
angle of view on a thing that does not
really exist as a physical entity and
and now you have just explained
how i have wasted a significant portion
of my life
trying to find that pot of gold
if you're gonna hide a pot of gold
put it at the bottom of a rainbow nobody
will ever find it exactly ever
ever
yeah so
just a little known fact now the light
that's inside the raindrop this is like
inside baseball here you ready for this
this is the head this is for this is
this is rainbow 201 not 101. so the
light inside the raindrop
right it sends out not only
one rainbow but multiple rainbows but
each next one is a little weaker than
the previous one okay okay
okay
and because the second rainbow that
comes out had an extra
extra reflection to it
if you ever see a double rainbow oh it
means you're tripping on mushrooms
if you see the technology
no no chuck it's just physics yeah
sometimes it's actually just physics not
the mushrooms you bring that's good yeah
okay gotcha so go ahead
two properties of that second rainbow is
one it's much dimmer than the first
gotcha it's always there but generally
it's very hard to detect because it's so
dim so it's much dimmer and the sequence
of colors is reversed oh no from the
original
that's okay that is first of all that's
dope secondly
who knew so the double rainbow
is kind of like the
reverse rainbow it's a it's an inverted
rainbow to the first rainbow and it's
dimmer there's actually a third and
fourth and fifth that they're called the
orders of the rainbow first order second
order third order but they they're so
dim
and if if the sky is bright you just
will never see them and there's a famous
youtube video some years back uh
i think they just called it the double
rainbow guy he's like yeah that's what
i'm saying he's tripping on mushrooms
and he sees two rainbows and he and he
falls prostrate to the ground
and said there is a god
[Music]
and that's how you behave if you don't
know physics right you just think it's a
it's a it's just physics really that's
all it is it's just physics yeah
once again neil way to ruin rainbows
nope
[Laughter]
i want you to reserve your sense of
wonder
for things for which we still do not
understand
ah and not apply it for things that are
completely understood
you know there will always be a moving
frontier of science where our area of
knowledge grows
so too does the perimeter of our
ignorance
leaving us with no end
of this universe to stand and wonder as
we gaze
wow
okay
thank you people that's the show
nothing ain't nothing left to say
nothing to say
that's it
that's it
so chuck there's more on rainbows but
i'm going to end it there that's enough
for one day i think yeah yeah you're
good with that yeah i'm good with that
okay all right that ends another
explainer next time we'll talk about
skittles
somebody's watching too much tv too much
saturday morning tv
i got kids man
i got kids
and i want to taste the rainbow
so
another star talk explainer neil
degrasse tyson here as always keep
looking up
[Music]
you